you know back in the days you know just
me and my team we always would say we
the best and I feel like everybody
should look in the mirror and say you're
the best but you know I'm screaming
Wiener bass you know to inspire and
motivate everyone I'm saying it's a
state of mind is important and and we
for real about it and you're blessed up
mrs. DJ Khaled father Mossad and this is
on the rocks another one I'm gonna show
you on my favorite watch but I first got
to put my sky dwell on cuz of this
matching my outfit and my chain playing
James you're saying clean I mean I think
the scholars with like 15 15 thousand
right I guess like a fifty clip it's
important key but this is my favorite
watch this one platinum Rolex I got this
for my jaw Christine you know I told me
I was like one of my favorite watches so
he went found it for me it's Arabic
numbers with a baby blue face it's more
than 50 I think it's like in the 60 70
you know maybe 80 I don't know it's all
applying them and a special special
edition I just like to get what I like
we call this the famous chandelier I
call a chandelier you're saying this is
baguette in the face bezel
wrist protect belief but just an
anniversary edition big faiths they have
one with the factory baguettes but it's
a smaller face yeah I'm saying I wanted
the big face anniversary what we did was
we put baguettes all in it and it turned
into a chandelier this cost this cost
you sure we like to talk about this they
try to tell me insight help I'm saying
but I to tell me
we gotta work something out now it's a
chandelier I'm saying like if you ever
need lighting when I'm doing a show or
some idoit be needing lighting you're
saying Sal I'm bright like a diamond you
solely so you know we got the classic
Rolex with the factory bezel this is a
classic you know just super classic
clean
another classic Rolex with the factory
bezel big ass but he busts down the
wrist piece and the side piece with
diamonds and baguettes I'm saying you
know some days I want to go bust down
some days I want to go straight no bus
down it just depends at the move I'm
saying it's just a vibe you're saying I
love this Scylla true it's some simple
clean you know I wear like almost every
day you know my basketball shorts white
teeth just chilling I love a sky girl
with like a blue face it was a gift
actually from David Lee David Lee gave
me this and as I'm not mistaken I think
he's a limited I'm not mistaken I don't
you say I'm just I'm being told where
they told me but it was a gift and I
like it that's all that matters that I
like it I can show you this one this is
the rose gold tech this you're saying is
something beautiful I'ma be honest with
you I love this bus down one but I'd
rather have it not bus down like I said
but I always have the option just a case
I feel like busing it down he was saying
I love this Hublot right here this is a
do a collaboration with Hublot you know
I love putting these on with Miami Heat
shorts like team you're saying I've had
this for a wild man Unitas dad's home
team you got Dwyane Wade salute what I
love about watches is the reminds me
it's always my time that should be your
time always many as in you know it's
that time it's always time to hustle
always time to grind I feel like you
know sometimes we have different ways to
glorify our success I'm saying some
people like to buy new shoes about
sneakers i buy watches whatever you like
you know work hard and get it you know I
said sometimes I feel like wearing
change sometimes I just don't and this
chain right here is special jay-z gave
me this it's a Rockefeller piece with a
Cuban and this is you know I'm just
being honest this is like was personally
his this wasn't like y'all me give you a
chain and the right piece no no this is
his mic his off his neck like his I'm
saying so this is like very special to
me and I'm honored and I'm grateful to
have this gift and I remember the day I
got it was special day and you know it
was just beautiful who says she shot out
of jay-z
this right here was a gift from Drake
Drake bought me this when my son was
born he got me with beautiful two keys
father a son I have one key says Khalid
and the other key says aside I didn't
expect no gift from no one I'm saying it
and I got a gift from Drake you know
first of all I said my brother's family
and I just appreciate everything he's
done for me and my career and then for
him to buy me a beautiful gift for me
and my son I mean it's a lot I'm saying
so that's a special oh absolutely
everything's for him you know I wear
this a lot this is um so broke chain
with my son's name into the side we got
the classic line key my Jordanian says a
gift if I'm not mistaken like red ruby
eyes you know this might be nothing to
anybody this means a lot to me I'm
saying like the smallest ones mean the
most to me not because it's smaller
nothing just it says the lie and the key
but each key leads to the next key
you're saying and this is line order you
know lying key and that's key you know I
got the keys I'm saying my son has one
too all praise you changed the Most High
God you're saying this is a prayer beads
my Queen bought me this it's just
beautiful it said always protect the
blessings you saying well then you got
your classic rope chains you know you
never know you might put different
changeup the rock pieces that wrote one
day to the Cuban
[Music]
of course it's also one of my favorite
simple clean we the best logo small
chain every day where every time I have
one end up giving somebody like it's
like my 100th one cuz I just give it to
somebody every time there's a fan or a
friend yo Sal just giving it all the
time and you know we make these
consistently and I'm it's important to
me it's my logo is what I represent it's
my brand sweeter past this is a clean
pinky ring little rose gold go with the
Patek right
we call this pinky these are all
baguettes I got this with pristine shine
bright like a diamond with a bracelet a
match it just feel good with the
chandelier it's just a vibe you're
saying I coming fresh out the shower
boom jumping your whip and you start you
just like it's special you know Sarah
it's always greatness to have
straight-up diamonds you know sometimes
I wear on the same listen or watch
sometimes I wear it like that sometimes
I wear with this you know just something
clean it just be a five you're saying
all my gold watches always wanting to go
bracelet just in case I want to wear a
gold diamond bracelet you were saying
just in case I want to just hit him with
a a blame here I'm saying bling-bling
I always loved jay-z's watching green
gang I've always loved puffs cuz it's
like just enough you know you hit them
with a serious watch and maybe with a
serious pinkie that's how I rock but
also a big fan of the meego right it
don't stop
like the me go there's no way to catch
up it's impossible they they don't have
a designer new chain or a ring by the
second I just love seeing my brothers
just iced out they go all out it'd be
100 bracelets hundred changed I love it
when I see them do that that's one thing
GQ and I want to thank everybody all my
fans for you know getting that father
beside Billy Kylie Kylie DJ Khaled thank
you
[Music]